how do you but it was a very good
episode yes yes well I love seeing you
guys doing so well and by the way thank
you and it feels like there's a certain
amount of Freedom now too that's why
we're talking about all these this
sadness
I mean I'm alone in this house I have to
admit to you there is a genuine
sadness it has to be yeah it's I feel
alone
you know before maybe a little time at
the sex clubs be okay no you it's fine I
have to go through this this is healthy
yes that's exactly my mom said you
called her to come over the other day
she did okay yeah to clean okay he's
just watching movies
Dr Drew
um he calls he's got your mom to clean
the house because a girl is coming over
that's not me
you've got the coolest mom on Earth
she's like hello I asked her like where
are you going I gotta go see Bobby
and I was like why he goes oh he has a
girlfriend tonight I'm like okay
how does that make you feel probably
helps you with a lot um honestly it
makes me feel like we're probably gonna
be friends forever that's good because I
was so sick that never happened
she said you guys had dinner together
and then that's it yeah yeah it was yeah
me and your mom had dinner yeah um uh I
wanted to sorry did you want to no but I
want to say that you know over the last
nine years
when I was laying in bed I would hear
dogs barking and people talking in the
living room and life and stuff so there
is and the cats don't make any noise
every once in a while right but um now
every once in a while but it's so quiet
in here and I think it's healthy
it's and I'm the grief is definitely
healthy it is and I'm just processing it
you know and it's um very surreal and I
have to tell you that I'm not even
remotely close in any way of being in
another relationship I just can't even
imagine that you know I mean I think
right now in the next couple of years
I'm gonna hit meetings and I'm gonna
grow and I wanna and yet you're right I
mean I like the excitement of like
dating people this and that but it's
just is it the grief I feel a very
intense feeling in my stomach is that
yours if there's like a grief you hold
here there's grief is it right here
right here yeah yeah yeah I feel why I
feel it why here though that's where
it's yours no it's I'm just
I'm a crazy I have this crazy ability to
do that yeah they're over a feeling of
grief yeah I feel where other people
hold their pain and I'm having this
really deep like right here but I know
it but you got to go through it yeah and
I know it's right yeah you've got to go
yeah go ahead but it's why but why the
way also because I'm feeling it I could
see I would prevent you from like being
available before any other religious no
way no way I'd like to add to that by
saying I know you're trying to tell me
you're you you aren't just going to jump
into another relationship because
somehow you maybe you think that that
would hurt me a lot no he can't it's his
feeling is I can't this feeling is
really you can't it will hold you back
but
they're a big part of me truly wants you
to find a partner that meets your needs
much better than I think that's why it's
going to be almost impossible
yeah I mean I you know I look at my life
and I look at how complex my schedules I
mean because there's even on dates I ask
certain questions
to see if you don't mean I I don't think
you should even be thinking about what
it is that my next relationship should
give me because I think you're going to
change so much in this next year of
sobriety and as you get through this
grief that wherever you are whatever
position you evolve into whatever your
growth is everything's totally different
to you and and you might even decide
I'll just date I want a relationship
right now whatever it'll be something
but I'm this feeling he's having which
I'm feeling you can't you can't it'd be
weird to try to be available try to even
relate to another person because you
can't get close when you feel like that
it's hard and and by the way and or
you'll jump over that feeling which is
not the right thing great he's gotta
feel it interesting I I do miss you a
lot I miss hearing your voice I I miss
you coming in and out of the room I miss
all of those things and I know that it's
necessary for this is just the
transition period oh my God I'm gonna
cry but I do miss you I miss you too
um but
um it's okay to cry what's wrong with
that
um
but let's do this no romantic yeah
um but it is such a weird thing like you
I Dr Drew on trash Tuesday basically
said the same thing to me which is like
I shouldn't there's just no way I could
jump into another relationship yeah for
different reasons but right yes that's
true yeah there's just I and I feel it
yeah I mean I two things are happening
where it's like I I want I have a hard
time just dating in the way you date
because I in order for me to have sex I
need to have like a mutual liking with
somebody and it I need to have that kind
of like deeper relationship to feel
comfortable with um before sex
um so that kind of throws me in a weird
situationship although yeah I mean there
are two different kinds of dates that I
go on right there's certainly women like
oh it's a sexual based thing right it's
right but there are some that there's
one I'm having sex with and you know I
mean that we have kind of a friendship
you know what I mean but it's like
um
but there are ones that I go on dates
where it's like it's not sexual as I'm
trying to get to know the person and if
she likes you should just be having fun
fun yeah communing with another human
yeah that's what it is it's like hanging
out and like getting to know somebody
again you know whatever but um I won't
talk about this anymore yeah
um I wanted one more question ourselves
I have one more question for Dr Drew
um is it unhealthy that I find myself
um kind of daydreaming a lot ever since
I was younger I would kind of just like
look away and for long stretches of time
it's part of that's a dissociative thing
right